all right let's go go to our friend john
paul jones john paul jones welcome back
um hey david thank you for having me on
i have three questions and
and
apology too so my first question is have
you uh have you been thinking about
going on crystal kyle and friends
second question
i want to ah as as there was an argon
where there's about a month and a half
ago about how biden doesn't think he has
enough friends
for vader putin in the war ukraine i
have if you were biting shields what
offline would you be willing to give
putin
and third i i started i started with a
progressive blog about three months ago
i've already posted my first two
articles
if i were to send them to you on twitter
would you be willing to read them and
finally i just wanted to apologize for
my behavior in the previous two calls i
understand i haven't been
the best caller oh my god i don't so
let's see so let's go reverse order i
don't remember your previous calls so no
need to apologize two if you send me a
articles on twitter i can't even look at
my twitter feed it's so over it's so
overloaded so i basically just look at
the verified feed i know that that's
very elitist of me but i just it's it's
impossible to see anything i get so many
messages and i'm honestly just too busy
to be reviewing other people's projects
right now number two um if i was on in
hold on if i was in biden's shoes i
guess going in reverse order we're now
at number three but
if i was in biden's shoes what sort of
an off-ramp could i imagine for putin
i've talked about this before it's
probably something where he gets to stay
in some of the regions he's already in
like the donetsk and luhansk or
something i don't know i mean i don't
love saying that but it's probably the
type of off-ramp that he needs and then
what was the first question
have you been thinking about going on
crystal with kyle's friends oh no no i
mean listen i i can't it's not i they
would have to invite me it's not have i
been thinking it's not it's not up to me
they'd have to invite me you know
okay um well i mean do you know of any
other progressive youtubers that i could
that could offer me some advice
advice what would you you want advice
from progressive youtubers
i'm i'm starting a progressive blog
you know rather than look for i would
just start the blog just start the blog
and grow the blog rather than getting
advice from people the the advice is
just do it do it as well as you possibly
can if you build it they will come
okay well
um thank you david um i just want to let
you can i just let you know
let you know um and know who i'm named
after i'm guessing you're named after
the basis for led zeppelin right i mean
john paul jones
actually
no the thing i'm actually named after um
my name comes from the founder of the
american navy john paul jones got it
okay
all right thank you john paul
okay well once again i'm sorry for my
previous two calls apology unnecessary i
have no memory of the calls there is
john paul jones what a phone call